ich habe eine große Angst einfach davor
um die Menschen die mir wichtig sind zu
verlieren oder wenn es um um die Zukunft
auch geht so da
verspüre ich auf den Ängste ja
bitte lasst mich meine Angst und mein
Leiter leihen
Angst kennt jeder sie ist ein wichtiges
Signal dass uns vor Gefahren warnt und
schützt zum Problem wird sie aber wenn
Sie unseren Alltag bestimmt sie schenkt
die Lebensqualität der Betroffenen
massiv ein der Blick ist tot und die
Sinne sind weltweit sind Angststörungen
die häufigste psychische Erkrankung noch
vor Depressionen durch die Pandemie
stieg die Zahl der Erkrankten von 298
auf 374 Millionen schätzt die WHO ja
vielleicht ist es auch die Angst vor mir
die Nacht so viel von meiner Tür an
das Gefühl die überhaupt nie wieder ab
die Gründe für übersteigerte Ängste sind
vielschichtig soziale Belastungen
traumatische Ereignisse erbliche
Faktoren und die Krisen der Welt gerade
der Krieg in der Ukraine belastet viele
sorgten sich im letzten Jahr 42% der
deutschen dass die Bundesrepublik in
einen kriegerischen Konflikt verwickelt
wird sind es 2023 55 Prozent
das Angst Level steigt auch bei Leon
das passieren gerade so viele traurige
schlechte Dinge auf der Welt wie wie
lange nicht mehr irgendwie auch mit
einer Frequenz wie ich sie noch nie
wahrgenommen habe ob es jetzt Pandemie
der Krieg die Klimakrise ist aber ich
habe selber gemerkt dass umso mehr ich
mich damit beschäftige ich mich sehr
schnell darin verliere oder
so heute sind wir eins alle gleich ja
der erste lässt alle rein wir können
keine Grenzen und wir lieben frei wenn
unser Gehirn echte oder vermeintliche
Gefahren wahrnimmt reagiert der Körper
mit Symptomen
ey es gibt Panikattacken und Menschen
haben sowas und
es wurde mir dann erst mit der Zeit klar
was das eigentlich ist
ich glaube das erste Mal habe ich das
eben gemerkt bei so Bahnfahrten das
Gefühl keine Luft mehr zu bekommen
Schweißausbrüche zittern auch oder
verkrampfen der Hände sieht jeden
Schritt den ich mache sie lauert hinter
jeder Ecke hinter jedem Gesicht nah ich
spüre wie schwitze mein Herz springt als
hätte es vergessen was Rhythmus des
Stars stehe ich da ihr kalte Atem in
meinem Nacken sie hat mich im Blick sie
ist da ich atme nur sie könnte mich
hören wenn sie mich erwischt hat sie
mich in der Hand ich kann man nicht
Krampf ab dann die Stange Abteil der
erstmal eine Taufe verzweif wird daraus
dass ich die Türe
Leons psychische Probleme beginnen im
Jugendalter in der Familie ist das Geld
immer knapp als die Eltern sich trennen
spitzt sich die finanzielle Lage zu die
Sorge darüber ist allgegenwärtig er
bricht die Schule ab beginnt eine
Ausbildung und geht nach Feierabend
jobben
es war eigentlich jeden Monat und das
Ding ey ist jetzt der Monat wo es nicht
mehr reicht ich glaube meine Mutter das
letzte was Sie jemals getan hätte wäre
mir zu sagen hey du musst mir helfen wir
können die Miete nicht bezahlen aber
irgendwann war es halt an dem Punkt und
in der Situation wo ich gerade selber
irgendwie auf jeden Fall nicht fest im
Leben stehe und nicht wusste wo ich hin
will und
auch einfach ganz viele Sachen nicht so
gut auf die Kette bekommen habe was
natürlich trotzdem enormer Druck dann
zusammen okay das muss jetzt aber so
sein und es geht hier eigentlich um das
Wichtigste um was es jemals ging und
zwar nicht um ob ich mein Abitur schaffe
oder nicht sondern ob wir ihn zu Hause
haben
der erste Schritt aus der Angst ist es
sich ihr zu stellen das macht Leon mit
seiner Musik denn aktiv werden ist ein
gutes Mittel
[Musik]
die größte Angst ist einfach so vor dem
Versagen ja hat es überhaupt einen Sinn
dass ich dass es mich gibt wenn ich
nicht irgendwas schaffe auch so eine
existenzielle Angst schon fast
[Musik]
ich neige halt dazu so unscheinbar wie
möglich zu leben sozusagen um nicht
aufzufallen und nicht negativ
aufzufallen
und ja so ein sehr beklemmtes
Gefühl irgendwie immer zu haben bei
allem was man tut
Angst kann den Alltag stark belasten
sowie bei der 34-Jährigen Julia
in akuten Phasen isoliert sich Julia
immer wieder obwohl sie weiß dass die
grübelschleifen dann meist noch
schlimmer werden und sie eigentlich
Struktur braucht
es tut mir wirklich schwer damit so
Routinen zu haben weil ich so ein Mensch
bin der super viel Abwechslung irgendwie
braucht
aber so bestimmte Sachen geben einem
halt einfach Stabilität im Alltag und
das hilft mir auch
deshalb ist für Sie wichtig bewusst in
den Tag starten
schon in ihrer Jugend spürt sie durch
den Leistungssport wie sich Druck und
Angst vor dem Versagen anfühlen auch als
Erwachsene setzen sich die Vergleiche
mit anderen fort sie lösen Stress und
dauerhafte Unruhe aus ihre Situation
verschlimmert sich es folgen
Psychotherapien und Klinikaufenthalte
ich bin aber eigentlich gefühlt immer
noch auf der Suche nach einer wirklichen
Diagnose weil damals habe ich halt die
Diagnose Burnout bekommen und deswegen
ja ist immer so ein bisschen die Suche
nach der Ursache für die Problematik die
ich auch habe und ja bin allgemein
einfach sehr offen was Therapiemethoden
anbelangt weil ich halt ja einfach
möchte dass es besser wird
schon seit langem wird Sport zur
Behandlung von Depressionen Burnout oder
Angststörungen empfohlen
klettern und Therapie aber ist ein
innovatives Angebot die Erfolge sind
besonders vielversprechend
klettern macht den Kopf frei
dadurch dass ich mich immer noch auf das
konzentriere was als nächstes kommt
unmittelbar das was als nächstes kommt
kann der Koffer abschalten
also ich muss mir keine Fragen stellen
was gerade zu Hause los ist weil ich
will ja darauf
keine Zeit für Grübeleien sondern volle
Konzentration auf das Hier und Jetzt auf
diesen Effekt bauen Larissa kranisch und
Sabrina Höflinger denn an der
Kletterwand geht es nicht anders auch
das Selbstwertgefühl wächst egal ob man
mit oder ohne Seil klettert
das sind Sportarten da wächst man
schnell und automatisch über sich hinaus
also man generiert einfach total schöne
Erfolgserlebnisse und ich
erfahrene Selbstwirksamkeit weil ich
trag ja niemanden da hoch oder schiebt
niemanden darüber und ich ziehe
niemanden da hoch möchtest du zu
unterbrechen
und
das für die für die teilnehmenden zu
erfahren dass sie spüren hey ich bin
handlungsfähig das das wird doch
klettern und das wollen sehr gefördert
vor allem bouldern ist ideal es wird
ohne Seil geklettert dafür in Bodennähe
und die Routen sind gut zu bewältigen
auch für diejenigen die nicht ganz so
sportlich sind die
Sportwissenschaftlerin und die
wirtschaftspsychologin bereiten den
nächsten Kurs vor in acht Einheiten
sondern Selbstvertrauen und die
Stressresistenz der teilnehmenden
gestärkt werden ziel ist es Lösungen für
den Alltag zu erarbeiten der Kurs ist
angelehnt an eine Studie der Uniklinik
Erlangen
die These lautete ob diese
boilertherapie genauso gut wirken kann
wie die Gesprächs oder kognitive
Verhaltenstherapie was jetzt so der
Goldstandard aktuell ist und es ist
rausgekommen dass es eben genauso gut
wirkt und dass die Ergebnisse einfach
sechs Monate später auch noch anhalten
und das ist natürlich Wahnsinn
Sabrina Höfling aber Teil des
Forschungsteams
gemeinsam mit Larissa Kranich
entwickelte sie das Konzept der
Uniklinik weiter ihre Kurse sind
alltagstauglich und eine Alternative zu
den vorhandenen Therapie angeboten
die Therapieplätze die sind beschränkt
unsere Kassensätze sind beschränkt also
es muss alternativen geben in Zukunft da
wusste ich natürlich noch nicht das
Corona kommt jetzt war Corona und jetzt
muss er noch mehr Alternativen geben und
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt war mir aber
auch schon bewusst das ist bahnbrechen
das ist neu das ist innovativ es hat es
ist niederschwellig ob sie mit ihrem
Kurs den neuen teilnehmenden wirklich
helfen können wird sich zeigen
therapeutische Hilfe finden das ist
schwer und langwierig gerade auch
abseits der Großstadt wie hier in
Rheda-Wiedenbrück eine Gruppe braucht
besonders Unterstützung psychische
Belastung von Jugendlichen und Kindern
weiterhin hoch das übernehme ich jetzt
erstmal ne
für März Psychotherapeutin Solveig
Düsseldorf
gegründet einen Verein der Menschen
unter 25 in psychischen Notsituationen
einen Kumpel für die Seele zur Seite
stellt dieser hilft die langen
Wartezeiten auf einen Therapieplatz zu
überstehen ich denke dass hakt an vielen
Stellen es ist einmal so dass die
Zugänge für Kinder und Jugendliche
außerordentlich schwer zu finden sind
auch für deren Eltern und Familien viele
wissen gar nicht wo melde ich mich dann
kommt das nächste das natürlich auch die
Therapeuten ihre telefonsprechzeiten
haben nämlich meistens im
Vormittagsbereich und sich das erschwert
zum Beispiel besonders den Jugendlichen
die sich ganz eigenständig auf den Weg
machen die Erreichbarkeit von diesen
Angeboten weil die natürlich nicht auf
dem Schulhof stehen werden und um 10 Uhr
mit dem Handy was er in der Schule zum
Beispiel auch nicht erlaubt ist bei
einem Therapeuten anrufen werden um zu
erzählen ich glaube ich habe eine
Essstörung ich brauche hilfe gerade
werden 178 Kinder und Jugendliche bei
den Soul Buddies betreut um sie kümmern
sich etwa 80 Personen überwiegend
Studierende der Psychologie aber auch
erfahrene Psychologinnen und
PsychotherapeutInnen sie beraten
vertraulich kostenfrei und
unbürokratisch die Nachfrage wächst
stetig 2019 hatten wir 100 was hast du
gesagt
137 und jetzt 2022 hatten nur 420 und
wie viel haben wir bis jetzt bis März
jetzt bis März haben wir schon 134 neue
Anfragen genau und die haben alle alle
wirklichen Probleme die haben Angst die
haben wirklich depressive Symptome die
können nicht schlafen
die können nicht in die Schule gehen die
haben ganz viele Sinnfragen ne als leben
die wissen gar nicht wohin mit sich
die corona-pandemie wirkt nach fehlende
Sozialkontakte und eine Zunahme von
familiären Konflikten während dieser
Zeit verstärken die Probleme bis heute
bei Kindern und Jugendlichen hat die
Nachfrage nach einem Therapieplatz um
fast 50% zugenommen
es ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz
ernstzunehmende Versorgungslücke einfach
weil sich psychische Belastung
chronifiziert zu psychischen
Erkrankungen das ist finde ich ein ganz
schwerwiegendes Thema weil gerade also
ist die Hälfte der Erkrankungen im
Erwachsenenalter die beginnt einfach im
Kinder- und Jugendalter das heißt alles
was wir da schon wieder stabilisieren
können ist ganz nachhaltig wichtig ja
für jede einzelne biografie
die 20-Jährige Lin hat Hilfe bei den
Soul Buddies gesucht sie kennt Ängste
und psychische Probleme bereits aus
Kindheitstagen
im Alter von sechs war sie schon mal im
psychotherapeutischer Behandlung
inzwischen weiß sie was ihr gut tut
Sport hat die Auswirkung dass ich quasi
einfach mal alles vergessen kann und
einfach nicht ausbauen kann und nicht
nur darauf fokussiere was ich gerade
mache und den ganzen Alltag drumherum
in der corona-pandemie war das normale
Leben auf den Kopf gestellt
Lyn kämpfte plötzlich mit neuen
psychischen Problemen Essstörungen und
extremer Niedergeschlagenheit
also vor zwei Jahren hatte ich
tatsächlich wenig Kraft irgendwie
irgendwas zu machen so gerade auch was
soziale Kontakte angeht und da war
gerade Sport und jetzt Tennis ganz gut
weil ich quasi durch das Training
gezwungen war auch was anderes zu machen
und für Menschen zu kommen und das dann
auch mal ganz gut getan hat
es gab schon damals zu wenig
Therapieplätze Lin befürchtete ihre
Familie mit ihren psychischen Problemen
zu sehr zu belasten darum suchte sie
eine Ansprechperson außerhalb der
Familie die Soul Buddies halfen ihr in
ihrer akuten Phase heute möchte sie
wieder bei ihnen vorbeischauen
in Rosenheim bei München startet die
neue bouldergruppe mit großen avatungen
und Sabrina Höflinger begrüßen ihre
neuen Teilnehmerinnen
okay wir sind komplett dann dürft ihr
euch gerne einen Platz suchen wo ihr
euch wohlfühlt wo wir jetzt die nächsten
20 Minuten ungefähr hier in unserer
Runde starten
sechs Frauen die hoffen dass dieser Kurs
sie bei der Bewältigung ihres Alltags
unterstützt denn allzu oft stoßen sie an
ihre Grenzen
[Musik]
mein Name ist Julia ich komme aus dem
Leistungssport auch und bin eigentlich
auch gefühlt immer auf der Suche nach
Heilung ja
ekliges Gefühl wenn man einfach sich
selbst so in Frage stellt so
warum ist man überhaupt da so
ja als schöne ist weil schön ist am
Leben zu sein und das ist halt oft das
spürt man halt manchmal gar nicht so
und es muss einem dann manchmal erst von
anderen gespiegelt werden oder halt auch
dass man selber wieder da irgendwie ins
ja dann Zugang dazu findet dass es schön
ist am Leben zu sein das ist auch schöne
Momente gibt und das nicht diese Angst
so
allgegenwärtig und alles einnehmen muss
das Angebot ist für Menschen die in
Depressionen Burnout Ängsten leiden oder
vorsorgen wollen den KursteilnehmerInnen
fällt es schwer ihre Kräfte richtig
einzuschätzen also wenn ihr im roten
Bereich seid seid ihr ein Stückchen zu
weit gegangen und was wir durch die
Achtsamkeit rauskitzeln wollen ist genau
erspüren zu können in welcher Zone ihr
euch aufhaltet und dann ist es okay wenn
ihr sagt
ich möchte das jetzt ganz bewusst
ausprobieren wenn ich diesen einen
Schritt noch gehe bin ich dann schon
oder panikzone weil zurückgehen kann ich
immer wieder und dann kennt ihr eure
Grenze einige Teilnehmerinnen warten
schon lange auf einen Therapieplatz
andere sind auf der Suche nach
alternativen Behandlungsmethoden der
aktive und spielerische Ansatz hat viele
Vorteile die bouldertherapie kann das
Selbstwertgefühl steigern und
Achtsamkeit fördern Glückshormone werden
ausgeschüttet Bouldern trainiert den
positiven Umgang mit Problemen
Ängsten und negativen Gedanken
drauf
ja super grau ist jede Theorie in
Rosenheim zeigt sich aber dass das
direkte Erleben an der Wand ungeahnte
Kräfte freisetzt im Körper und im Geist
die Gruppe gibt zusätzlichen Halt unter
anderem mal was so hergibt
[Musik]
was genau Graz kannst Du beschreiben
also klar ich bin voll erschrocken auf
jeden Fall aber
ja das ist in Ordnung ist einfach und
dass ich merke okay das war jetzt
vielleicht zu viel ist ich habe zwei
schon gemerkt so ein bisschen ja genau
und beim nächsten Mal läuft aber
wahrscheinlich besser
aus Angst beginnt klein und die Märchen
darüber nachdenken die mehr als die
bekommt der nicht den Raum sondern die
Angst nimmst Dich den Raum und mit
handlungsunfähig und das ist ja das was
wir hier üben und was bei so einem Sturz
jetzt hat hier passiert ist oder was
wird ja gerade zurückgemeldet bekommen
haben ist das dass es oh sehr gerne so
schlimm hier geht es darum der Angst
nicht die Kontrolle zu überlassen und
festgefahrene Denkmuster zu durchbrechen
für die TeilnehmerInnen nicht immer
einfach
gerade merke es hat dass man
Selbstwertgefühl
so kommt und wenn ich halt drin bin in
der Aktivität dann spüre ich halt auch
diese Kraft wieder so und das ist glaube
ich das was ich brauche gerade so meine
innere Kraft wieder zu spüren weil ich
gerade keinen Zugang dazu habe
[Musik]
mega
die nächsten Wochen werden zeigen ob
Julia so einen Ausweg aus ihrer Angst
findet
[Musik]
je früher Menschen mit psychischen
Erkrankungen geholfen wird umso
schneller kommen die Betroffenen im
Leben wieder gut zurecht das hat auch
Linnen gemerkt als ihr Hilfe bei den
Soul Buddies gefunden hat
hätte ich noch ein halbes Jahr länger
warten müssen hätte mir das sehr viel
Lebensqualität genommen weil ich quasi
so am sozialen Leben wenig teilgenommen
habe ich habe mich wenig nur noch mit
Freunden getroffen weil das war für mich
immer mit enorm Stress verbunden für
mich war das so okay ich muss einfach
wieder anfangen zu essen und alles im
Griff bekommen und dann läuft das wieder
so einfach was dann am Ende doch nicht
aber da brauchte ich auch ein paar
Wochen für was ich gemerkt habe okay ich
brauche tatsächlich professionelle Hilfe
und ich möchte mit jemand aus dem
stehenden darüber sprechen weil das auch
in der Familie viel Streit gesorgt hat
die Soul Buddies haben den aufgefangen
sie halfen ihr die schwierige Zeit zu
überbrücken bis sie einen Therapieplatz
hatte noch heute fühlt sie sich dem
Verein verbunden
und wie hast du das dann erlebt in den
Wechsel zum
Therapieplatz oder zum Therapeuten
eigentlich fand ich den Übergang das war
dann doch irgendwie relativ plötzlich
weil ich dann den Therapieplatz relativ
schnell gekriegt habe aber ich fand das
überhaupt nicht problematisch sondern
ganz gute nicht wusste auch weil das
auch so abgesprochen war wenn ich
irgendwann mehr gucke ich brauche doch
noch mal Hilfe mit irgendwas kann ich
mich auch wieder melden also
inzwischen hat Lynn ihr Abi gemacht und
studiert sie sieht sich selbst auf einem
guten Weg
[Musik]
das möchte auch Erkan erreichen er kommt
inzwischen seit sechs Monaten zu den
Soul Bodys
schön dass du da bist hast du gut
gefunden ja
Erkan hat Angst allein ein Kaffee
betreten in der Schule einen Vortrag
halten oder telefonisch einen Termin
vereinbaren lange waren das für ihn
unüberwindbare Hürden heute gelingt es
ihm besser wenn er Unterstützung von
vertrauten Menschen wie pia hat die
Masterstudentin in Psychologie ist sein
soulbuddy und steht ihm einmal in der
Woche zur Seite
genau ich hatte der von der
schulpsychologischen Beratung erzählt es
geht dann hier zum Beispiel diese
Einzelfallberatung bei
Lernschwierigkeiten und
aufmerksamkeitsproblemen und bei sozial
emotionalen Schwierigkeiten und eben
auch bei Fragen zur Schullaufbahn ich
meine das ist bei dir ja im Moment auch
Thema wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe
genau das steht jetzt tatsächlich auch
nur eine Telefonnummer drauf willst du
dort anrufen oder wie wollen wir das
machen
wir da ist ein Challenge auf jeden Fall
aber ich kann das also genau finde ich
richtig cool wenn du das machen könntest
genau hier stehen jetzt auch Uhrzeiten
drauf hier steht tatsächlich anmeldungen
sind in der Zeit von 37 bis 13:30 Uhr
möglich hast du denn nächste Woche
irgendein Tag wo du vielleicht später
Schule hast dass du da morgens anrufen
kannst
irgendwas aus oder ja perfekt ja super
[Musik]
Aufmerksamkeit und Wertschätzung geben
Erkan psychische Stabilität
[Musik]
also als ich Erkan kennengelernt habe
hatte ich den Eindruck dass er
ja aufgewühlt war irgendwie und
insgesamt unruhiger sowohl innerlich als
auch irgendwie äußerlich und mit sich
selbst irgendwie insgesamt nicht so im
Rhein und auch mit der Welt nicht so rum
rein war und ich habe schon den Eindruck
dass so mit der Zeit im Verlauf unserer
Gespräche jetzt sind so ein bisschen
Ruhe eingekehrt ist vielleicht und auch
so ein bisschen so eine gewisse
Zufriedenheit mit sich mit dem eigenen
Leben entstanden ist
die Soul Buddies helfen er kann seine
Empfindungen und Gefühle besser zu
akzeptieren er ist selbstbewusster
geworden und tritt in der Schule
sicherer auf
Hoffnung habe ich auf jeden Fall ich
habe mehrere Mut gekriegt und jetzt kann
ich besser kommunizieren also ich ich
rede noch an meinen anstrengen noch da
aber es ist leichter als in September ja
optimistisch bin ich auf jeden Fall ja
ich glaube ich ich werde das schaffen
und ich werde einen Platz suchen also
finden ja
keine Brille auf deswegen muss ich ja
ein bisschen mehr kommen
heute in einer eigenen Wohnung er hat
ein Musiklabel gegründet und baut gerade
ein neues Studio auf
in seinem Leben tut sich viel
seine Mutter ist froh dass es ihm besser
geht
ja ich hatte Angst klar weil der noch
bei mir gelebt hatte können mit dem Bier
zusammen diese Mitte sagen können und
die sexistenzarzt habe ich übertragen
klar ja aber was ich kann das finde ist
der hat es verarbeitet und
der gestern sein Leben weiter
Musik machen das hat Leon geholfen seine
Ängste auszudrücken und anzunehmen
dadurch kann er jetzt den nächsten
Schritt gehen
also ich habe nicht darüber nachgedacht
dass eine Psychotherapie eine Lösung
sein konnte sondern habe dass er gesehen
wie er wenn ich das mache dann es ist
irgendwie eine Art aufgeben weil ich
muss es ja selber schaffen
mir ist auch erst relativ spät bewusst
geworden diese Ängste wirklich als
Problem und auch als etwas zu sehen
woran man arbeiten kann und vielleicht
auch sollte
bis jetzt habe ich mir noch keine
professionelle Hilfe gesucht das ist
etwas was mir für dieses Jahr auf jeden
Fall vorgenommen habe leon hat erkannt
den Weg aus der Angst muss er nicht
allein gehen
in der Boulderhalle steht heute die
nächste Stunde an Sabrina Höflinger und
Larissa Kranich wollen ihren
TeilnehmerInnen ein besonders wichtiges
Thema vermitteln auf den inneren Kompass
hören
[Musik]
wenn ich hier so stehe wie weit komme
ich was ist meine Spannweite was ist
meine Reichweite
was ist meine Grenze
Grenzen können mit Ängst Zusammenhängen
weil wenn ich ständig meine Grenzen
nicht respektiere dann ist irgendwann
mein Tank leer und dann bekomme ich
natürlich Angst oder andersrum ich mache
mich immer kleiner ich setze meine
Grenze selbst zu nah ja und verkaufe
mich selber unter Wert aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen aus
unterschiedlichen Ängsten Julia testet
als erste welche Radios für Sie am
besten ist
die Übungen an der Boulderwand können
helfen einen gesunden Umgang mit den
eigenen Ressourcen zu finden
ob das überhaupt ob man es braucht also
vielleicht passen die Grenzen auch so
wie sie sind so wie sie natürlich
sich anfühlen
[Musik]
ich wünsche jeden Teilnehmer wenn noch
mal so ein tiefes Tal kommt und das
kennen wir ja alle dass ihnen
Notfallkoffer haben den sie sich selber
bestückt haben und dann das rausholen
was sie in dem Moment brauchen um
erfolgreich und aus eigener Kraft aus so
einer Krise rauszukommen
die Boulder Therapie wirkt nach
Julia lernt Stück für Stück ihre eigenen
Stärke zu vertrauen sie merkt dass sie
mehr schaffen kann als sie sich
zugetraut hat
mein Kopf war also auf jeden Fall dass
ich starker bin als meine Angst aber
mein Kopf ist auch genau der der
dazwischen spuckt ja es glaube ich
braucht einfach noch ganz viel Arbeit
und auch Geduld mit mir selbst damit ich
wirklich meine Ängste
nicht so dominant werden lasse damit ich
die im Zaum halten kann ja aber ich bin
überzeugt davon dass ich stärker bin als
meine Angst
[Musik]
mehr
ja ja keine Angst mehr
[Musik]
ich habe keine Angst mehr